welcome to games spots now playing for
Wolfenstein the New Order yeah a brand
new firstperson shooter that just came
out today yesterday dude yesterday a
brand new firstperson shooter that just
came out
yesterday I'm Sean mcginness and this is
Chris wat hey folks and we're going to
play it it's Wolfie time so uh we played
a little bit of this on the lobby
yesterday today I I saw me doing some
train station trying some stealth and
then fighting some big old Soldiers so
we're going to hop around a little bit
today we're taking some requests for uh
action so uh first some of the requests
we had were to see some stealth so I'm
going to go ahead and boot up a chapter
here that's got uh this starts out with
some stealth going to try to infiltrate
a prison in order to free the uh some
resistance
members and we're going to play it on
all right Sean which one do you think
think here can I play Daddy H this is my
so far I played like the first hour or
so of Wolfenstein up until the late
title card uhhuh but this is Far and
Away my favorite part of the game this
is your favorite part are the difficulty
selection screen portraits which here
let me show you a trick okay you ready
for this yeah let's see it the trick is
to just cycle them like this and imagine
a timeline in which a baby would go from
really basic innocent looking baby to an
evil murderous man with blood all over
his face demon baby just fill in the
gaps yourself this is my favorite thing
to do hello I'm BJ
Blas won't you come kill some Nazis
with oh that's too good yes let's do
this oh I'm feeling quite
angry that's the whole game we're just
going to do rest of this stream all
right uh I'm G to play this on Uber
difficulty wow and okay we're going to
get a quick look at uh BJ and Anya
having a nice moment in the train uh
this is a good time to remind you that
this is rated M for Mature yes oh yeah
so if you have people watching who are
sensitive to adult themes I.E violence
that's the whole game but sexual themes
in particular such as sexual violence
start your VCRs
now are you comfortable
sharing
what do you need me to explain this to
you no no I know how adult situations
work sometimes you just need to feel
yeah PJ does this muttering to himself
thing throughout the game sometimes when
he's in the coidal Embrace with Ana
other times when he's killing Nazis
pretty much a lot uh I like it cuz it
gives him some extra character I know
where to go I way to get inside prison
there's hey if you guys have questions
did you mention this already no uh if
you guys have questions about the game
feel free to jump into the twitch chat
on twitch.tv/ Gamespot or leave comments
on the on the page on Gamespot for now
playing and I'll uh take a look at both
of those and we'll try to answer
whatever questions we can Chris have you
completed this game no I haven't
actually uh I've gotten quite far in
fighting the Nazis but I haven't beaten
it yet I do like you saw that trick they
did during the cut scene just or during
that um I guess this this is a pre one
of the pre-rendered cut scenes there's
the in engine ones I don't know what the
difference is in terms of production um
but they did the cut from Anya sort of
naked getting out of bed to in the hotel
they do those kind of jumps during the
story and they're really they're really
kind of slick I like them a lot it kind
of keeps things moving at a good Pace uh
during these sort of in between story
moments I don't think those are even
pre-rendered cutcenes really like the
one we just saw here yeah because like
I'm playing the game on PC mhm and it
actually looks different depending on
what like depth of field settings you
have enabled and stuff so I think yeah I
think those cut scenes are actually in
engine they just apply some extra
cinematic effects to them cool so here
we are in uh Berlin listening to uh some
announcements what we have a beautiful
morning keep an eye on that uh subtitle
because you'll start to hear some
delightful Nazi propaganda you'll have
great work to perform for your
Fatherland I'm going to try to get onto
the roof of that prison bus to get into
a prison all right let's see it and so
do a little sneak around here just let
me remind you to stay true to the values
of the Reich as a member of Germania you
are a supreme human being a Supreme
Being acts with force and
ambition Supreme Being despises weakness
and strives for a Perfection so as you
can see echoing a lot of that Nazi
propaganda business honorable and
pure I'm going to stab a lot of those
people who are honorable you should
definitely stab a lot of those dudes cuz
they're Nazis yeah yeah they're bad they
do bad stuff all right so here's where
you
get the first your first like uh little
cutting Implement I'm going to go a
little bit quickly through this part cuz
I have already done it and it's sort of
one of the more exploratory sections of
the
uh of the game so it does it what I like
about one of the things I like about
Wolfenstein the New Order is the way
that it does this kind of exploratory
stuff yeah overcharge my health and then
it'll slowly count down does it like
this exploratory you can like cut you
know in here there's actually a a
painting that I grabbed on a previous
playr um just gives you a chance to like
poke around the environments a little
more and take your time a little bit
more uh that's not always the best for a
live stream but it is but in terms of
like a game that does like stealth
Action and then just like you know balls
out and shoot a ton of Nazis it's nice
to have some varying
Pace um yeah just going chop this thing
open yeah yeah go for it go through that
hole yep I'm going to chop this thing
open too this part these cutting stuff
is not the coolest but whatever think I
can fit do you think I can fit through
that I think
yeah Noe yeah just a little hop just a
quick little hop good and like there's
some there was a treasure in there that
I got to earlier um but once you so I'm
playing I've traveled back uh in my
playthrough as you saw I just loaded a
chapter I've actually kept um my health
upgrades that I've gotten so my Max is
170 Health when generally you start off
at 100 uh well you do start off at 100
yeah and
um that that same applies to weapons in
some cases
but not in this case where you just sort
of start off with no weapons but I do
have a knife which I can stick into that
individual and um this thing doesn't
shoot yet so it's strictly knife times
uh when you're doing stealth this is a
very healthy handy mechanic which is the
lean I'm holding I'm playing on the Xbox
One by the way you hold the left bumper
and then uh you can kind of lean you can
do like fourward to to the side you can
like do a little dance you can go up and
down get really low to the around and
that's leaning uh we've got a question
in the chat room from eminent stranger
who's wondering uh have I experienced
any bugs related to the PC version of
the game uh he says apparently there are
crashes and performance issues mostly
with AMD uh I am running on an Intel
machine and it's been fine for me uh it
actually runs pretty well on my machine
which is a GTX 670 with a i5 2500k so
you know not the most Cutting Edge PC
but I can uh I can run it on uh nearly
maxed out settings yikes that's where
you just get in to a straight beat down
fight with a Nazi and uh just stabbing
each other clubbing me I'm stabbing
thought stabbing you oh what's up Robo
dog this doggy has are you going to
stealth kill this Robo dog yes I really
am going to like look at this horrible
legs like this is a real Abomination
that thing shouldn't exist you should
that is an affront to God and man good
night oh sweet doggy and now I'm going
to take armor legs are all SPL out like
that I'm going to take its butt armor
and put it on my head and now I have
more
armor BJ is nothing if not a good
improviser okay so how do the health
upgrades work because I know early on
you can get above 100 but that's when
the number turns yellow and it's just a
temporary thing that ticks back down to
100 oh can you write this number down
for me actually what the the entirety of
that yeah just write it down in like a a
little text field little text edit over
my text edit app yeah so this is like
there you can collect one of the
Collectibles are these Enigma code files
and then when you're in uh the extras
menu actually I'm going to answer this
phone real quick when you're in the
extras menu you can go there and there's
like a decoding thing for decoding
Enigma files and doing that unlocks
extra game modes so I'm pretty sure that
uh which number did you want me to write
down I'll show you again in a
second basically I'm just listening to
this dude talk about the bus rolling up
and
because I'm Mueller I'm not answering
him he's getting super salty I'm getting
a glimpse into like Nazi workplace drama
here he's about to drop some f bombs on
mu yeah oh no dude I the the ethernet
cable hasn't been plugged in I guess it
got on Conn for a little while all right
shut up just hang up DJ hang up the
phone calls over so some of that stuff
like here just write these numbers down
all of those down yeah what am I a
stenographer just write the numbers down
you don't have to write the math no I
got to do the math I don't want to miss
any of the subtle details of the game 5
plus 6 equals 11 that checks out 1+
1 equals 2 and I'm not exactly sure if
those numbers actually I'm going to
share this with you on Google Docs I'm
going to call this
important math document
parentheses naked pictures of sake Tumi
cool there we go that's good yeah I
don't want to confuse that with my uh
other documents that are also not naked
pictures of sakumi I don't know why see
I picked up these files I don't know why
I don't know where they
go does my map show anything it just
shows the commander so you can pick up
maps in a given level that'll show you
where sort of like treasure or
unlockable stuff is oh hey
whoa yeah so this is a classic
Wolfenstein touch is the secret rooms
the secret corridors I didn't even know
that was there nice I have not
discovered this
before but that's that's kind of how you
do it right you you sort of spot things
that are a little conspicuous and then
uh go figure it out boom I've got
another Enigma code which is cool and uh
like I guess I could have seen this room
on the map in the Shaded area but yeah
neat finding Secrets all right let's go
kill more Nazis please good
work so sometimes you know you can get a
little playful with the Nazis like
here's a commander listening to some
music you're going to snab him in the
butt or the neck I'm just going to like
do a little swaying back and forth dance
into the tunes I just want to say BJ's
use of jezz hands is pretty on point
look at it just kind of like whoa whoa
whoa which way do you want me to stab
this guy is he doing the douge this kind
of stab or that kind of stab no
definitely oh no the other one all right
yeah
what gross all right so that dude's down
I'm pretty sure I look at his body look
at his body look at his look at his
little baby legs dude he I bet he
couldn't do that position in life that's
a tough yoga position that is and so
there's also these little articles you
find around like first German lands on
the moon so this is kind of establishing
the alternate history lore of the game
yeah right cuz no German has ever been
to the moon no German no German has ever
been to the moon ever ever as I maybe
maybe maybe there was secretly maybe a
secret German on the I don't want to
offend our German viewers by implying
that no German has ever been to the Moon
and you're not just implying it Sean
you're outting out saying no German has
ever been to the
Moon neon Neil Armstrong might have
secretly been a German so if you can see
These Guys these are the these are the
dudes I'm trying to rescue uh or I guess
I don't know if I actually know that for
sure yet but like they've got these Man
in the Iron Mask things going on which
is just like a real creepy
touch this game is full of those real
creepy touches yeah um yeah a lot of the
uh exotic technology that the Nazis have
developed in this world is a little
unsettling all right so now we go and
get on this this crazy train to prison
Town
um yeah that's one of the things that
you know you you
really oh we're getting getting psyched
up here let's just check this out from
miles I wonder if there's anything in
this world worth saving
dis
tyranny enemy of endless
might I'm wondering if I have any
friends left
standing Nazis getting pissed at other
Nazis about parking
jobs Germans love efficiency and there's
nothing less efficient than incorrectly
parking if this is where they're keeping
you I will find
you and set you free he's very
determined all right so now we start the
infiltration of Eis involved
prison this involves
sneaking now do you have to sneak here
or is this a choice of your own
uh I don't know I mean I I don't know if
you actually have to sneak at any point
okay so there's no moments in the game
that you've encountered at least where
it's like instant fail upon detection no
I no I have not encountered that uh nor
it's just holy crap there's a ton of
Nazis you have to kill now upon
detection I wish I could slide tackle
this guy that would be dope instead I'm
just going to punch him in the head and
stab him just give him a little head
punch yep but I don't get to take his
baton which is kind of a bummer bummer
summer bro
cutting through some chains there's some
dudes down here like I'm being pretty
cavaliere I did
not uh I was not this sort
of bold on my first playthrough I
definitely Tred to take it a little
slower cuz I think you know I try to
preserve the
stealth see now there's dog food but
there's no dog I'm going to find that
dog maybe that's a hint it's a hint that
I should eat the dog food aint here's
your question about the health earlier
Sean whenever you go whenever it says
overcharge then you're going to go over
your max health and that slowly counts
down so like basically the benefit of me
eating that dog food besides just like
feeling like a real subhuman was nil uh
but you can get much larger packs uh you
know that help you overcharge in moments
of uh in moments of need in moments of
combat but other than the overcharge
you're going to see I didn't cut it low
enough for myself to just go
across the other thing to consider about
health is there is
um that guy's alarmed oh he sees me oh
God no just be be real yeah
okay your health regenerates to the
nearest multiple of 20 so if you drop
down if I were to get into a fight and
drop down to 90 health I would only go
back up to 100 if I dropped to 80 you
know if I dropped to 81 I would go back
up to 100 if I dropped to 79 I would
only go back up to 80 so it sort of
straddles the line of regenerating
health and not regenerating Health
essentially because so you know you're
down you're down to it you got like two
Health left it's not as dire as all that
you're going to be up to 20 you can like
take a hit maybe but you're still going
to have to be very cautious and very you
know you want to be very mindful about
your health
uh which I think is actually a really
smart way to handle it and sort of
preserve that tension of no regenerating
Health come to me kill him kill
him that was a bad job now we're getting
into stab fight okay there's a dog
there's a doggy coming where's the doggy
ah come on doggy step fight step fight
oh
what oh welcome to the next gen of
console gaming so this is happening on
this specific debug Xbox we've been
playing it on okay so this is not like a
retail this I have not encountered this
problem at all on my home console I
unplugged the wre the the freaking
internet so this wouldn't happen but now
it's happening with the wireless because
it's sort of connecting normally it pops
up and it's just a menu that lets you
try again or cancel but now it's all
it's hung up just cancel you stupid
idiot that's an issue that oh haven't
encountered anywhere else so I'm just
going to actually take a quick second
here to try to turn off that wireless so
that doesn't happen again sorry folks
this is the part of the now playing
experience where you get to really dig
in to the Xbox one network settings
there we go disconnect
Wireless all
right yep yep super fun super fine
you're good all right let's go back over
here
so see like I broke stealth there that
Nazi definitely saw me I don't want to
get seen by this thing it will kill me
but I do want to bust these boxes hoping
because and this isn't exactly stealthy
there should be some health in here but
there's not so oh
gosh so see I'm at 111 Health now it's
going to go back up to 120 but then it's
going to stop okay so yeah stealth not
necessary in certain situations the
times when you really want to be careful
about stealth or when there are
commanders around okay those are the
guys who call in reinforcements exactly
so if they call in reinforcements it's
going to make your life significantly
harder
um oh yeah it's going to make your life
significantly harder so you want to take
them out as quickly as you can uh and as
stealthily as you can because then then
you can just oh God oh God oh God oh God
oh
God slide
away so that's a poner hun and I'm going
to try to get away from
it oh God it's coming still maybe I
don't know where I am
okay okay okay all right all right
that's fine you're good you're
good um
hello uh
hello
uh hello okay he's coming you're good
you're good just wait till he turns the
corner and then just give him the old
knife in the throat trick yeah the old
stabon yeah no problem Sean you can do
that no
problem come on where is this guy where
is
this stab him in the G oh he just told
me he was going to punch my face
in I mean I I appreciate that dud looks
pretty tough
yeah all right we're going to go pretty
quickly through this section
actually I'm going to try to do a little
bit more stealth and then we'll get to
some some guns blazing stuff yeah I want
to see some of the crazy guns oh you
want to get I want to see like dual
wielding auto shotgun kind of [__] oh
yeah kill this dude you want to see me
kill this guy in the toilet situation
shoot him in the head I don't have a gun
man that's
weird but I can't give him a swirling
you punched his throat in like you caved
in his esophagus whoa and then oh that
was necessary you had to flush the
toilet yeah I did if anything if
anything you did him a favor because
then he's not dying in his own
urine I did him a favor by stabbing him
in the back of his head wait I just need
to check is anyone else here no okay
okay you're good did you like that that
was good that was good I like those
animations you can tell that they had
fun with those dog food real quick so in
that case I ate the dog food it put me
over like I was at 140 the dog food gave
me 144 and now I'm up to 160 these dogs
are not the
smartest that guy is asleep I'm going to
stab this
dog oh is this the one I think this is
the room where you get to do the the
Kill from the
trailer
uh so check this out you just clubbed
him on the head so hard though yeah
that's true all right so this is one of
BJ's delightful onliners let's listen
up you're dead yeah what did he say
before you're dead wake up you're dead
that was for you Mary Kish she requested
that specifically that's a good one so
some of those I think I wrote These
numbers down already but put those in
your Google doc what am I just am I
writing down the sums or the math just
write down what when you say write down
the numbers but you don't have to write
down all of them I know you mean no I
don't know Sean this is just I'm going
to write down this holy equation 8 * 9 =
72 parentheses 7 + 2 =
9 all right all right I'm going to put
that in my important math document fix
that transcription error you wrote
71 freaking what worst stream partner
ever I'm just saying I all I ask is you
write down a
number simple number all right so this
so see the signal detected thing you
guys notice in the top right that's your
indication that a Commander's around if
this guy gets alerted a ton more people
are going to come
but [__] really took it to that chair I
really did not mean to do that I hope
that he did not actually get around to
calling more it didn't seem like it
seemed like he was a little preoccupied
with trying to Club you to death with me
getting St so what point are you going
to get a gun uh all right forget that I
am going to need a key come on this guy
doesn't have a key on him it's like a
key heav kind of dude seems like a key
Dude where's the key show me the
question Mar oh there's some heated math
discussion in the twitch chat oh cuz
that wasn't actual math right that was
weird
math hey here's a question from Brent
Banner in the Gamespot comments he's
wondering can you throw the knife at any
point you can't throw this knife but you
can pick up knives to throw okay they're
special like smaller KN yes and so you
definitely can throw knives um all right
this is maybe the last section you're
not going to beat me to death I'm going
to stab you a lot nice very impressed
this is like sort of a there's a puzzle
to solve if you go down here you can get
like um a bigger battery for your thing
actually I think I need to get that cuz
it turns my thing into a
gun
yeah give me
that oh crap yep cuz now oh get him like
this is a gun now I'm just missing this
guy's face but I didn't miss it that
time what a
dummy oh real good question from
Senor Sensei who asks can you do wield
knives yeah can you do kn Kimbo or is it
you can you can do kniv you can do
knives a Kimbo yeah can you do it now no
now I can run from ponzer hun ponzer hun
Schnell Schnell that's German for watch
out there's a dog behind you so you
better I'll ass you have a pretty solid
command of the German language that I
did not expect you to have Sean yeah
well you I'm pretty impressed yeah all
right I'm going to be breaking out of
this prison soon and there will be guns
I promise you can do
this I think you should follow that B
sign for Blasco
witz coming in hot oh no oh okay oh it
was on the wrong mode
oh that dude really thought that he had
the upper hand on you and then he got
shot in the brain with a laser gun got
zapped in the
face ziggity Zapped all right so now I'm
in the Cell Block I'm coming up on uh a
gun
situation there will be shooting
although first I have to rescue the
prison n we are at the top
here come on
baby
nope you always hate that when you like
get to the top of an
elevator
to
all is this the gun version
yes knock
knock oh what's
up oh what is le
so this is the prisoner situation wow
right this is you can kill these guys
though right no uh or these story
critical dudes no these are not these
are these are my my resistance friends I
mean yeah but they're also prisoners so
so blow blah blah blow blow no he's not
he's not shooting them you know these
guys you know they they made their
decisions they're the ones who robbed
the liquor store to get thrown in prison
right you know you got to do a lot more
rob a liquor store or to get thrown into
a Man in the Iron Mask it's
true all right so now we're going to
talk a little bit to our
friend uh now this there's actually one
choice you can make in Wolfenstein the
New Order that splits it into two
timelines where you end up with
uh a different character accompanying
you through the story so Sean if you
made it to the late title and you made
that choice uh I go too much into what
that choice is and I'm not going to
actually actually no I will'll watch
this movie cuz pretty soon the uh the
Nazis are coming I'm going to take a
drink of water uh and um
yeah there we
go boom that guy's not making it
out all right yeah put a table in front
of it so
loud all right come on put that table
there the Nazis are here man oh he's got
so much blood on his face EJ so this is
basically the first time that you other
than Ana this is the first time that you
have encountered
anyone anyone who like you might be able
to fight with any kind of resistance so
BJ is obviously very determined that's
true so uh uh I like that like totally
nonplused by the fact that his face is
covered in
blood I mean that dude's seen a lot of
[__] over the years he's seen some crazy
crazy
[__] hello
friend you're not going to
be all right so now that I've got
my ginty little
pistol I got some
bullets some Nazi hats I love the image
of BJ just stacking Nazi hats on top of
his head over and over again he got a
series of Nazi helmets on top of his
head yeah yeah I believe it so I can
like you know Team Fortress 2 style oh
you don't want
to this is a little this is a little
cocky that was bold and I really like
your approach there it's just the
execution could use a little bit to be
desired all right so now I got to shift
into like all right we're actually in
Uber difficulty mode you can't just run
and shoot them in the face like that
unless you're going to be super on point
which I was not in that case so the
loading times are actually H they're
okay they're not super awesome but
um right back into it here going to grab
my shotgun and actually take advantage
of the fact that I am
playing uh having been very far in the
game I have this alternate ammo for the
shotgun which is uh bouncy Flack pellets
uh so even if this guy's hiding behind
cover I'm going to kill him with FL
pellets but then there was a guy behind
the door this is the point at which it
becomes very apparent that you're
playing on the maximum difficulty level
and this is the point where I stop
blowing it you can do this I
promise because yeah was a little lazy
so here we
go oh that was a different one that was
fun
okay
shotgun we're just going to hang back
here a little
bit all right that's a little far for
the shotgun to handle let's try some
hand gun
action you got this homie boom all right
Booyah that should do it for those guys
oh no oh no no no no no no okay 25
health so yeah 25 Health but then you
want to wait till it goes back up to 40
before you grab any other health cuz
otherwise you're just kind of
hamstringing yourself in terms of how
much health you
have meanwhile
what yeah is that all of you frakin nzg
nzg that's my pet term for the Nazis for
the Nazis all
right now I've got my assault
rifles
what's happening in
here
oh oh he's going to take care of that
guy no Fergus well done
friendo okay so now I got to get set up
for this uh Prison Break which is
actually quite tough but fortunately I
have another advantage in that I've got
the alternate fire for these two guns
dual wielding is easy to do at anytime
you just press up on the d-pad uh now
I'm going to try to prepare the way a
little bit by looking and
spotting oh like this guy is dual
wielding worth it when you when you burn
through ammo that much faster it I mean
in certain situations it definitely is
like if I had dual wield assault rifles
coming down this pipe I definitely would
have done a little bit better than I did
okay uh just cuz you put so many bullets
into the into the to the
NZ that they can't help but succumb all
right so things are getting crazy now
you got this out in prison town you got
this
homie and I am going to try
to
GTFO which involves shooting these
things which are the automatic Sentry
cameras and then also spotting these
guys they're good shots on Uber
difficulty so you want to make use of
that lean which can you can know you can
lean down you can lean over you can sort
of do the do this funky little Wibble
wobble come on stick your dumb head up
oh he did just as I was going for his
toes or I can switch to the rocket
attachment that I have and totally miss
him a jibs BJ you forgot how you shoot
there's automatic all over so if you get
caught out by by Nazis on Uber it's
pretty it's going to be over pretty
quick as we saw earlier so I'm going to
take this Corridor easy try to do some
lean
stuff take out that thing there if I'm
sometimes they'll shoot you even up
through these areas so like quick pops
out of cover to scout are a good way to
to HED your bets and then uh move
onward who is shooting me I know someone
is trying to do it do a shots at me you
can do this you got this homie
oh there he
is come
on he get man oh is he dead is he dead
is he gone is he gone and
dead what is going
on so many bullet noises where the Nazis
all right let's go down one more there's
a slide in cover thing have you used it
much Sean slide into cover no yeah or
the I mean the you know the run and
slide run slide no we were talking about
this earlier what the [__] what the [__]
who was that damn do you remember the
Run slide conversation we had I do I was
prompting you subtly to bring it up
again and share your concerns so as I
mentioned earlier in the Stream um I'm
playing Wolfenstein on PC with mouse and
keyboard and very early on into the game
it uh introduces the Run slide mechanic
into you and you actually have to use it
to progress through this little tutorial
bit and it's just it struck me as
awkward because you have to hit left
shift and left control controll which
are both keys that I would hit with my
pinky like I don't normally bring my
ring finger over there off of the a key
uh-huh and it just felt like really
weird like I had to roll my finger onto
them simultaneously yeah um and it just
it struck me as one of the kind of
examples of this game is maybe designed
for a controller more optimiz for
especially when you factor in like the
weapon wheel and that type of thing
which is this is just hold down R RB
yeah whereas like a with a with a mouse
you scroll through and it kind of goes
like clockwise or whatever oh God
there's a Pon
hor that situation but somebody later
told me that you can just tap shift and
it'll enter a run State and then you tap
control and then it'll do the slide so
you don't have to hit them
simultaneously just kind of like combo
them but um but yeah no I played about
an hour of it and I'll be interested to
see if I end up switching over to a
controller or not I would say for the I
would say like you know running and
sliding like around a corner in an
aggressive way is can actually be pretty
tough yeah but like and when you're
fleeing from someone you know if you
want to slide around a corner like that
to get away from gunfire in that
direction that's a good move but like
running up on someone and sliding into
them you'll be able to pull it off on
lower difficulty levels let's look at
some Nazi signage here you know lift
with your legs not with your back don't
don't stand so close to me uh
oh
God hello oh so in the chat they are
mentioning In fairness all the keys can
be rebind I just haven't tried that yet
like I said I only did an hour or so so
maybe I'll find something that's a
little bit more suitable where is
that oh
freaking he I am very impressed with the
PC version of the game it it looks
really good and uh it's not too Hardware
taxing either what do you think about
the Xbox One version uh there are
certain like the lighting is a little
bit flatter I would say compared to PC
but Xbox One version looks good mhm I
wonder what the PS4 version looks like I
haven't seen that one uh well at least
in terms of the cut scenes it looks
identical our guys were saying there's
we've actually got a graphics comparison
going up that's going to yeah actually
them side by side I heard that this is
one of the games where there isn't like
a big disparity between xbone and
PS4 who was shooting me oh you're over
there yeah I think that I would agree
it's definitely not uh not a huge oh
someone restocked the dog food how
thoughtful so again using the this is
just the the lean mechanic that I'm
using I'm not even like ducking and UND
ducking
oh and I got an AR magazine perk so
that's another thing actually oh crap
crap crap crap crap
crap try
to what up a brick a that was that was
real good see you're employing that
running slide pretty well so far I'm
trying but that was stupid I
lied you were employing it quite well
super poorly all right one of the things
you saw pop up right there is that is a
perk I had I think I killed enough of
enemies using the AR assault rifle that
that perk comes up that perk indicator
and that's there are these sort of light
bonuses you get throughout while you're
playing the game it's sort of they
happen naturally during the course of
play but um all right hold
on I'll take a look at them real quick
here so they come in four different
flavors stealth tactical assault and
Demolition and so you know demolition is
a lot about grenade tossing I haven't
killed the commander with a grenade yet
so I haven't gotten too deep into this
one but assault is like you know it
increases the ammunition you get and the
like the speed with which you can reload
and increases the magazine sizes and
stuff like that really the only
impactful one is this one that which is
unlocks your ability to throw knives at
a Target but again this stuff all
happens very early on so it's kind of
worth uh targeting these but not
necessarily going to going to totally
change the game on you all all right
let's get through this part
here you go away oh there's a
doggy my God it's a total
Uprising don't shoot that guy he's your
buddy what if you shot him though maybe
shoot him I can't you can't he doesn't
no it doesn't the gun doesn't fire when
he's there oh it's like real
life yeah take that Nazi concrete
barrier so there's some light
destructibility in the environments at
least when it comes to cover yeah
definitely so like shredding that cover
was definitely a good way to but like if
you shot at the big wall behind them
that wouldn't like crumble away it's
kind of like preet things yeah
definitely all right the sight of your
previous death you remember how a bunch
of dudes came out of that doorway yeah
you going to go Auto shoty on them I
want to but at first I have to go Auto
shoty on this
guy you shot that dude in the butt and
he was real angry and then you shot his
leg
off that blood stain o oh that he wasn't
dead why am I going desperate stabs I
always do that I always go panic stab
during a Reload it's not like a real
good surv
ttic do not
recommend oh crap all right this is so
this is one of the first sort of big
enemies you encounter this is a dude I'm
not going to get too close to him but
he's basically a shotgun heavy that I'm
just going to kind of pepper from afar
with my dual wield now this is a little
tricky cuz I have to like you know I'm
leaning out so I'm holding with my index
finger the this bumper and then it when
you're dual wielding it's left and right
trigger are the left and right triggers
oh
crap oh what happened to your parts I
shot them off oh God no grenade I
thought I had a
grenade hey it's not super badass to
like make worried noises when you're
shooting dudes with a shotgun but you
know what is super badass dual wielding
Auto
shotguns all right so those seem like
they weigh at least 50 lbs each yeah
well BJ is a real muscular dude so
that's true his name is BJ he's got no
problem with this all right that's the
area I was infiltrating before I'm all
set in there uh we're going to go head
back out here and Rend de with
Fergie get some armor and see what we
can do with these dual wielding
shies
I saw
you oh his whole arm no yeah so enemies
jib all right to certain
degrees kind of a pet peeve of mine that
you have
to like reach down and pick up ammo not
a huge fan of
that oh yeah oh dual wielding so fun
come on I see you back there oh pop oh
no oh in the toe he fell over oh
delightful the whole world is bugger a
blasz they [__] it up they
did that's right
Ferg they did we're going to un W oh
that guy really just kind of came out of
nowhere you know that wasn't that wasn't
my greatest situational
awareness going to put a ton of Nazi
hats on my head there is a lot of
running around picking stuff up in this
game yeah and that's like you know like
I'm saying like I don't I don't you you
kind of got to do it oo doggy food my
favorite you kind of got to do it
because otherwise you're going to run
low on ammo but especially here
um but it's I'm not a the biggest fan of
that mechanic it kind of makes you like
run through the environment staring down
at the ground which is not awesome
oh this part is difficult as I
recall come on
doggy that dog you shot it in the face
twice and it died and its dead body slid
through your
legs see like two shotgun guys in the
hallway I don't know what Harden perk is
but like oh my God that's like 40
shotgun shells did I just shot down that
hallway all right now I have nine
shotgun bullets left so yeah there is
kind of a drawback to using the dual
wield am you can burn through ammo real
fast when you're dual wielding I'm going
to dual wield these ARS for a little bit
cuz I seem to have more of that ammo get
some Tesla grenades I think there might
be a little more shotgun ammo here so
I'm going to actually reload just to
have my quick swap cuz you can you can
quick swap between with Y uh between
your most recent weapon um and that's
handy so you don't have to resort to the
wheel in
combat
die and like this this whole area would
have like would probably have some uh
Enigma codes hidden in it or uh maybe
some Nazi gold but once you play through
it and revisit the chapter all the stuff
you've grabbed like that collectible
wise uh goes away so that you don't you
know redundantly collect stuff uh so
you're not actually seeing a lot of
those Secrets but rest assured they
exist uhoh oh get oh wow that was not
one of the prolific stabby ones I
actually remember this part pretty well
cuz I was sorely vexed by it on my first
playthrough so that's why I'm uh being
pretty confident all right oop ubby
dooby ubby dooby
difficulty where's the there's one more
guy peekaboo peekaboo that was a lot of
bullets for not a lot of killing that
guy oh so much blood splatter damn it
Ferg oh
Fergie fortunately I have the rocket
attachment to the AR which you don't
actually get for another few levels but
which I got there so this is the end of
the level I'm going to clear the way out
here
go maybe we'll just do one a little more
accuracy Fergus is going to go get a car
we're going to drive away and then I'm
going to just quick load uh two other
places on the map I don't know what time
it is how how much time we have left on
the stream I'm going load 10 minutes 10
minutes 10 minut jeez all right well I'm
going to load two other spots on the map
just to give you guys a quick look at
uh some other parts of the game another
question from Brent Banner in the
Gamespot comments he asks can you only
dual wield the same weapon types yes oh
yeah uh yes you can only do wield the
same weapon types so double pistols
double shotguns double assault
rifles um double marksman rifles you get
later on you are not able to dual wield
the
laser oh
gosh here we go into the
sewers have you ever you ever wonder
what Nazi poop smells like you're about
to find
out not you personally but BJ is going
to find out all right uh so we're going
to quit to the main menu and just load
up two more spots one of which I just
want to give you guys a quick look at
um there's this place the the Nazi safe
house that you go in between missions
where you sort of get to explore uh it's
like a it's like downtime you get to
kind of look around read some articles
sort of take like talk to some of the
people who are in the resistance with
you uh there's an Easter egg there that
I'll show you that's pretty cool uh I'm
going to skip this movie just because
it's for the sake of time and also uh
for the sake of you guys knowing a
little bit less if you're thinking of
playing the game so this is the
resistance safe house you can like you
know maps of Berlin and articles about
the war on the wall but that's actually
something we did earlier um you know
this is a room where you meet an very
eccentric uh sort like math minded but
very traumatized woman actually this
lady techla what's up girl look at all
those screens on the on the wall there
yeah we're tapped into the uh I guess
the surveillance network of Berlin or
something like that um you can go
upstairs and this is sort of where the
bedrooms are and oh where the magic
happens yeah there's resistance Magic
this is Max's bedroom this is the
memorial sort of column Memorial slf
fire hazard yep has serious fire hazard
cuz ventilation in here there not much
but let's light up ton of candles
anyways uh towards the back here you can
practice your knife
throwing which is a little tricky cuz
there's a there's definitely a lot of
sort of dive on them and if you saw me
try to knife a Nazi commander on the
stream I did not do very well and then
there's this like tiny room in the
corner you can go to which has something
you might recognize here uh shot from
the old uh Wolfenstein 3D and then you
can go to sleep on this bed and have a
nightmare and have a horrible nightmare
in which you are still the same
resolution BJ and weapon but you're in
Castle
Wolfenstein so I I'm pretty sure this
scales to the difficulty of where you
actually are in the game so I don't ever
do very well at
this um so I'm going to try to do a
little bit better and get a little bit
further yeah someone was shooting me
from over here I think
also no all right he got some ammo for
me like what is happening to this guy's
Sprite I don't really know that's how
that's just how it was get some I don't
know why the health isn't
turkey but uh you know we can't can't
always get what we want I love the
classic music so
good overcharged health I think there's
going to be a Nazi behind this door come
on no just a just a grim
skeleton dead
man and I don't have any like oh I guess
I can doal wield handguns maybe I'll do
that actually I really don't have a lot
of bullets but we'll try it in that
helped that was good give me your
bullets
good it's weird how some of the things
are rendered as they were in the
original game but some things aren't
like obviously there's your hands and
like the actual like geometry of the
world too yeah I can jump yeah
oh that's good that's really good how
they leap into the air to
die all right who remembers where a
secret is which one is
it do I just run along the
wall tapping
X not sure if there's a secret in here
but I guess we should always check the
Hitler Port portraits right
all right let's go this
way you got
this horsey says it's always in between
the plants in between the plants the
plants were there some plants out here
uh there are by the
door nothing that really stuck out to me
so let's keep going we'll see
Wolfenstein the New Order same as the
old
order what is that up chamber pot I
think that's a poop bucket as they say
in German I a pooping
bucket yeah I don't know
German oh give me that dog food sweet
sweet dog
food
nope this is the true nightmare you try
to go poop and the bucket is actually
two-dimensional and there's no room for
your 3D
poop ah that is the worst part about our
modern Human Condition
wait so go back to that that big room
you were in initially why let's see
Mouse Madness says secret is next to the
door on the brown
wall next to it
yeah not getting anything not getting
anything not
no X is the like wuse button they say
that wooden wall is very short and and
the wood panels are blocked by these
trees Twisted Tootsie says it's just a
matter of poop
perspective which is a very clever poop
joke well done oh gosh yeah and twisted
Tuesday has just won this stream
congratulations to Twisted
Tuesday or the best poop joke of them
all all right anything hidden behind
these terrible barrels no terrible
barrels
all right I got good health
situation BJ oh I can slide too
man always on point 69 says what game is
this I thought this was
Wolfenstein always on
69 always on
point yes this is Wolfenstein it's the
wolfi of all
Stein anybody like this is one
yeah so see it even popped up there with
the little uh the little prompt look at
this about to supercharge my health and
get
the so this is this is the old assault
rifle that you get to use in the early
part of the game shoot
Hitler done take that
adol really taught him a lesson
M Bob says terrible barrels is the title
of the new Dave Matthews Band album
terrible barrels terrible
barrels wolfy times wolfy times wolfy
times
wolfy who's around this
corner yeah just blew your mind didn't I
didn't expect anyone to lean in your
world yeah
I don't know what to
do I don't actually know how long this
goes on oh god well we've got about 3
minutes until it's 3:00 so you choose
how to spend those 3 minutes however you
wish hell of dying hell of
dying all right and so then it just
kicks you back here and you don't
actually get you can't just like go
right back in and do it you uh don't get
another chance to play until you either
reload the chapter and visit this safe
house again or until you
um come back around finish a mission and
come back to the safe house so I think
that's pretty much it maybe we should
load up one more thing sure or we pretty
much just a real quick taste of
something all right let's go into the
future a little bit and we're going to
go to this one ah we're going to use the
unter sea boat yeah this has some pretty
I'll skip this scene in case anyone is
uh story sensitive but suffice to say
I'm gonna try to hijack a youo yeah
because that's a smart thing for a
blaskowitz to
do so this is another this is actually
one of the sections where stealth kind
of matters a bit more I guess um
you let's see so I did this section
stealthily when I first played it and
then I did it not stealthily just a
little bit ago and um well Na's not very
not like super on point with the seeing
of you
uh so you know if you clear this section
stealthily you're not going to get an
alarm and you're going to be able to
enter the next section also
stealthily but if you do get
alarmed this silence pistol is the bomb
uh if you do get alarmed they're going
to they're going to like give the crew a
heads up you're going to hear the
captain like make an
announcement yeah buddy in your
grill oh another dude over there oh oh
right in the chest nice work
yeah this is actually the level on which
you get the ricocheting fla shells which
I will now put to
use you should I think my health is
pretty low so it's probably not going to
last very long that's good cuz we are at
1 minute to go on this stream any last
questions about the wolf about the
Wolfenstein about the Wolfie times get
your questions in now twitch
chat uh it's out on PC Xbox One and PS4
also Xbox 360 and PS3 which I didn't
think it was coming to current gen
systems but yeah uh it totally
is um yep there's a bad guy say hello to
the bad guy bad guys are you alive or
just death break dancing always on point
69 says this game reminds me of turro
always on point 69 never lets us down
with his insightful commentary on point
really on point oh and then I died so if
you play it I recommend actually playing
it on uh if not Uber then
definitely uh I am death incarnate or
whatever the fourth out of five is I
feel like it's going to I feel like it
might be a little too easy on normal
although to be fair I haven't really
played it a lot on normal in any case I
really enjoy it we gave it an eight Dan
Hines down in Australia reviewed it um
we had a segment on the lobby about it
yesterday and we've had a bunch of stuff
on it so far if you guys have any
further questions about it feel free to
reach out to me on Twitter uh and uh let
me know how you're enjoying it if you're
actually playing it I know uh aanti
who's often in the chats I was saying he
liked the characters of Max and clous
sorry we didn't get to show off today
but those are two of the guys in the
resistance that you get to know and it's
it's a game with character it's a game
with this old school kind of shooting
sensibility it's a goodlooking game it's
fun H happy May happy May thanks Sean
thank you Chris and thank you guys for
watching see you next time peace
out